[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and
welcome to episode
number 115 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform Podcast.
I'm Mark Mandel and I'm here
with my colleague, Melanie
Warrick.
Melanie, how were
you doing today?
MELANIE WARRICK: How
are you doing, Mark?
MARK MANDEL: I'm doing great.
You're here in the studio
with me, so I'm super happy.
MELANIE WARRICK: I'm still
in the studio until--
MARK MANDEL: Still.
I love that, still.
MELANIE WARRICK: [LAUGHING].
Never left.
No, after this I will actually
be heading out to New York
to go to FAT*, but that's for
us to discuss later at the end
of the podcast.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
but today we have
a really interesting interview
with two people, Dom Elliott
and Stewart Bryson.
Dom works for Google Play,
and they are basically
a client that uses Google Cloud
Platform to look at analytics
across Google Play,
and Stewart Bryson
is one of the people
who helped build it,
so we'll have a
fun chat with them.
MELANIE WARRICK: But
as always, we always
talk about our
cool things a week,
and we end with a
question of the week,
and this week's
question is if you
want to be able to unit
test your integrations
with Kubernetes with
client go, how can you
mock what happens inside the
cluster in your unit tests?
Locking is always a challenge.
We'll get back to that one.
So, cool things of the week.
I'm going to start
this week and mention
how Amy Unruh, who's
one of our developer
advocates who we had on the
podcast a couple weeks back
talking about AutoML, she has
put together a blog post that's
talking about easy distributed
training with TensorFlow
using the TF estimator train
and evaluate on Cloud ML Engine.
This is something that allows
it to more easily train
and transfer models, whether
you're running it locally
or distributed in the cloud.
She gives a nice overview of
how to do that, especially
specifically using
Cloud ML Engine,
but this is something
that you can
use with different
infrastructures
like Cloud Engine,
Container Engine, Google App
Engine, so she gives a nice
insight around what to think
about and how to approach
this, and how to use, train,
and evaluate, and
we will definitely
link that in the show
next as we always do.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
I will go next.
One lovely contribution
from community member
on Medium, "CI/CD with
Less Fluff & More Awesome,"
written by--
I'm going to go with
go with Rik Nauta.
I'm going to guess that's right.
He's writing about,
basically, by combining
several different things.
Cloud Builder, an
open source product
called Keel, Pub/Sub, Helm,
GitHub, and Kubernetes,
putting that all together
into a continuous integration
and continuous
deployment pipeline
so that basically they can write
code, turn it into a container,
put that container
into a registry,
and then deploy that container
up into Kubernetes as well.
It's actually quite
a thorough article
that has lots of code
in it, so if you're
looking to build a
continuous delivery pipeline
and maybe you're interested
in any of those products,
you might want to take a look.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes,
definitely, and last thing
that's cool thing of the
week is that we basically
have generally availability
on the Google Compute Engine
machine types with
96 VCPUs that have
up to 624 gigabytes of
memory, so basically you
can now take advantage of
performance improvements
and increase core count provided
by the new Intel Xeon scalable
processors, the Skylake.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
Yeah, and that works both across
custom machine types as well
as pre-defined machine types
as well, so more cores.
MELANIE WARRICK: More cores.
MARK MANDEL: More cores, better.
MELANIE WARRICK: All right.
Well Mark, I think
it's time to go talk
with our guests for
this week's podcast.
MARK MANDEL: Let's
go do that then.
Today I am excited and pleased
to have two people here
joining us today.
Dom Elliott, who is the
global developer marketing
communications person
for Google Play,
as well as Stewart Bryson, who
is the owner and co-founder
of Red Pill Analytics.
They're here today to talk
to us about how they've used
GCP with Google Play marketing.
How are you both doing today?
Dom, how are you doing?
DOM ELLIOTT: Yeah,
very good, thanks.
Thanks for having me.
I'm over in cold London.
MARK MANDEL: [LAUGHING].
Excellent.
Stewart, how are
you doing today?
STEWART BRYSON: I'm
doing fantastic.
It's a little cold in Atlanta,
but probably not London cold,
so I'm happy.
MARK MANDEL: Oh.
Oh, I didn't realize.
You're in my old hometown.
I live in Atlanta for
a number of years.
STEWART BRYSON: Ah, excellent.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Well, before we get stuck
into talking about Google
Play marketing and what
you do with Google Cloud,
why don't you tell us a
little bit about yourselves
and what you do?
Dom, do you want to go first?
DOM ELLIOTT: Sure.
So, I'm on the Google Play team.
My goal is to help
Android app and game
developers be successful
on Google Play,
and the way I do that is
to lead the [INAUDIBLE]
to developers, so we tell
them about all our new product
launches on Android
and Google Play,
help them understand our
features, produce case studies,
and then use various marketing
channels to reach them,
like our web site,
developers.android.com,
and we use YouTube, blogs,
Medium, social channels,
a lot of email marketing.
We speak at events, all
those kind of things.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Stewart, you want to go?
STEWART BRYSON: Sure, yeah.
I'm the owner and co-founder
of Red Pill Analytics.
We're a company that's
about four years old,
employ around 30 30 people
in the US and Brazil,
and one individual in the UK.
We focus on analytics.
That's our bread and butter.
At the beginning
of our company, we
were firmly an on prem
analytics software company,
and about two years ago,
we made the transition
to trying to go after
the public cloud
and really helping all
size organizations,
really, move their--
either new implementations,
or their existing analytics
workloads into the public cloud.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
Well, so you both have
been working together
on this project.
Can you tell us a little
bit about the project?
DOM ELLIOTT: Yeah, sure.
I'll start.
As I mentioned, we use a
lot of different channels
to communicate with developers,
and we have a really large,
engaged developer community
who develop for Android.
It's the world's most
popular operating system,
and we want to make
sure that we're
measuring the health
of the ecosystem,
and checking that we're
reaching the right developers
and that they're engaged
with our channels
and content to make
sure that we can
understand how they engage with
our content and our channels.
MARK MANDEL: And so
in the past, we've
done this in a
fairly manual way.
Every marketing channel we use,
like our website or YouTube,
or our social media
accounts, they
will have their own
products that you
can log into to
start to pull data
to see how many people
you're reaching,
what they think of your content,
and where people are engaged
and that kind of thing, and
it would be super manual.
We'd do every month or whenever
we need to pull a report,
you've got to go into a dozen
places, pull all this data,
try and present it
nicely in Google Slides,
and then share it
around internally.
It's just a big waste
of time, really.
If you're doing that, you're
not putting your effort
into actually creating content
and engaging with partners
and helping people,
so we thought
that there was a
better way, which
is when we started
looking into what
Google Analytics, specifically
Data Studio, could do,
and how that could work
with Google Cloud Platform
to actually pull all
that data in one place.
MELANIE WARRICK: How did
you end up connecting up
with Stewart on the project?
DOM ELLIOTT: So Stewart was
actually a recommendation
of a colleague of mine.
We wanted someone
with some expertise
on these various products,
Data Studio and Cloud Platform,
and I think it was a
Data Studio colleague who
mentioned Red Pill Analytics,
so we got in touch.
STEWART BRYSON: We're
so glad they did.
We approached this very much--
even though it was Google,
and Google's a big company,
obviously, but Dom's team is
just a group of marketers,
right?
So marketing communications.
So we approach this very much as
we would any marketing company,
really, although they
are Google and most
of the avenues and
digital channels
that we were interested
in are Google platforms,
they're public Google platforms,
so this implementation
will be applicable for
really any organization.
We knew that, also, that
because Dom's team really
didn't have access to
engineering resources,
we wanted to make
this really easy.
We wanted it to be something
that they could support
once we left, which was
very, very important to us,
and so the Google Cloud
Platform was perfect.
So we focused on
serverless technologies
as much as possible.
We focused on things that
would just scale and continue
running once we left,
and the platform really
provided a lot of technologies
we could use really
pretty easily.
MARK MANDEL: So just so
this is 100% clear as well,
even though you're
both basically working
for Google Play,
you're basically
like an external
company using GCP.
There's really no
difference here.
You're not getting any
particularly special treatment
as far as I can tell.
DOM ELLIOTT: No, yeah.
Exactly.
From a marketing
perspective, we're
pulling all this data
from, essentially,
public APIs via Google
Analytics, Youtuve analytics,
and so on, and then even some
other non-google platforms
like Twitter and LinkedIn.
STEWART BRYSON: Yeah,
it was very much an API
driven approach.
We did utilize
BigQuery data transfer
service, which is also
available to anyone,
to pull something straight
from Google platforms,
but in general, the main
approach was to go after APIs.
All of the social media
and digital channels
have APIs with data
readily available.
We just needed to
consume it and ingest it
in a straightforward way, get
it into BigQuery eventually,
and then just let the
power of Data Studio
really give Dom and his team
a single point of access
for all this data so that
they can see which channels
are performing, which channels
are reaping the most benefits
from their outreach.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
is there a reason why
you chose to go with GCP
versus using internal tools?
DOM ELLIOTT: I'm not really sure
what internal tools we'd use.
Most of our internal
tools are kind of--
we measure very closely usage
of our products and things
like that, so I work
on a product called
Google Play Console, which
is how developers publish
their apps and kind of manage
their app business on Google
Play, so we look very closely
at usage and engagement of that,
and see which features
are working and so on,
but that wasn't an obvious
internal tool to pull together
the various sort of
marketing channels
that we're talking
about like web,
and video, and email
and things like that.
So I'm sure some clever
Google engineer could
have built something
from scratch,
but it it just seemed
really obvious to us
to use what was
publicly available.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So, I want to take a step back
because we've mentioned the end
product in passing, and
we're not a visual medium,
unfortunately, so
people can't see it.
But Dom, can you
explain the end result?
What do you see here?
What is Data Studio give you--
what is the actual product
that you have finally
built at the very end?
And then maybe we can
move backwards from there.
DOM ELLIOTT: Sure.
I would sort of
describe it as a--
if you were traditionalist,
like a living version
of presentation, and
each slide is essentially
a report on a different
marketing channel that we use,
and it's really visual.
It's in Data Studio.
It's got graphs and
stats, and each graph
has trends versus
previous months.
We sort of slice data based on
different things like country,
or engagement by
different dimensions
depending on what the data is.
We have about 11 different
pages in this report, one
for each of our main
marketing channels,
going from web, to app, to
email, to ads, to video,
to blog posts, and then social,
and then events as well.
MELANIE WARRICK:
And is part of it
used to help decide
where to spend
more efforts towards
different marketing channels?
What are some of the
decisions that you
like to make off of this?
DOM ELLIOTT: At a
high level, it helps
us understand the
health of each channel.
Are these channels growing?
Are there particular
countries which
are very engaged,
or not very engaged,
where we should dial up
or dial down our efforts?
For specific channels,
we can see if--
for the app data we
pull in from Firebase,
for example, when we
release an update,
is that resulting in a sudden
increase or a sudden drop
in engagement we can see
those kind of things,
and then it helps us a lot with
the various pieces of content
we put out on channels, as well.
It helps us with optimization
and planning going for us.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
DOM ELLIOTT: Another
use of the report
is internal reporting,
essentially,
so we can tell
various stakeholders
in all the other teams,
the product team, business
development team, our
various VPs, when they just
want to dive in and just get
a snapshot of what's going on,
see how engaged and
developed the community is
in various places, and they
can do that pretty easily now.
When those kind of fire
drills came in in the past,
we would all have to run
along and pull all that data
on the fly, but now we just
have it all in one place.
MARK MANDEL: Lovely.
So Stewart, I'm going
to come to you now.
We have the GCP podcast.
You mentioned
previously that this
is a lot of serverless stuff,
sort of unmanaged as much as
possible.
What products did you actually
use to build this whole data
pipeline?
STEWART BRYSON: Yeah, we went
through several iterations
and the total project length
was about three months.
We took a look at, really, the
landscape of all the products
we could use.
We initially considered
data flow, but really
for these, for instance
Twitter has a streaming API
and JavaScript, really
fit the bill well,
so at the very heart
of this is App Engine.
App Engine is the
application is pulling
all the different
social media APIs,
so App Engine grabs that
stuff, and initially
our first iteration was
just App Engine to BigQuery.
Some great node packages for
writing directly to BigQuery
from JavaScript, and that
was the initial iteration,
but then we started
to rethink it
as we added additional
social media channels.
So we went after Twitter,
and then LinkedIn,
and then we looked at
Medium, so as we architected
this in a very iterative
way, we started
introducing some other aspects.
So Pub/Sub became
valuable for us
because initially
we're streaming data--
we're using the streaming API
to pull data from Twitter,
but that doesn't give
us likes and retweets.
The streaming API
doesn't give that,
and that's really what Dom's
team was super interested in,
so we had to use the
batch API against Twitter
to pull all those
retweets and likes,
and Pub/Sub subscriptions
made it very easy
for us to manage going at the
data from multiple avenues,
and then again, we
started to, as we ingested
more and more social
media sources,
we introduced Cloud
Functions, and Cloud Functions
allowed us to be a little
bit more event driven
in how these different sort
of social media messages
are processed.
So the final
architecture was, really,
App Engine, pulling data from
all of these different places,
ingesting into Pub/Sub, and then
having Cloud Functions react
to that ingestion.
And part of it was just using
the Natural Language API
that Google has
available, so we were also
tracking sentiment analysis,
which wasn't really
initially one of
the requirements,
but it was so easy to do
that we started doing it,
and I think Dom and his
team have really gotten
good value out of that aspect.
Not just seeing how
many retreats and likes,
but also measuring the sentiment
of those different social media
messages.
MELANIE WARRICK: So that's great
that you're using sentiment.
What are some of the ways
that you're applying it
in terms of utilizing it for
decisions that you're making,
or how are you
looking at sentiment?
DOM ELLIOTT: On Twitter
and LinkedIn in particular,
we're seeing how sentiments
tracking over time.
We're looking out for any dips
or any particular increases
and seeing what are the
popular posts around that time,
and because of the
data we're showing,
we can then go and
see which handles
are getting a lot of
engagement around those tweets,
and then maybe we can, if
it's something a little bit
negative, we can
see if we can help.
We can point people to
our support resources,
or to our operations
team and if there's
something we can help
with, if there's something
we should escalate
on Google Play.
Or if it's positive,
maybe we can retweet it,
or look at what the
developer audience is sort
of enjoying and engaging with.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice,
and then Stewart,
that was a really
great overview in terms
of that type of products
that you guys are using.
What were some of the challenges
you were up against when
you were building this out?
STEWART BRYSON: Well, time
was one of the things,
so we had to build this in
a reasonably quick amount
of time.
Three month project for
this many data sources was--
I won't say daunting, but
an on prem implementation
would have taken
much, much longer.
I think the idea that
we were just able to--
there's no provisioning,
just get up and get going--
was an important part.
I think also in a
project like this,
we often focus a lot
on the data movement
and how the data is ingested
and ultimately finds
its home in BigQuery,
but sometimes Dom
had some very specific
visualization requirements.
He knew what he wanted
it to look like.
He wanted to be
able to present this
to management and to
the rest of his team,
so really, Data Studio
shines in that way.
It's based on Google Drive,
so we can make changes
to Data Studio reports and
dashboards as Dom was watching,
and he could even dip
his hand in there a bit
and say, no, I'm
thinking more like this,
and we could see those
changes at the same time.
So it's really unusual
for an analytics tool
to have that kind of
interactive capabilities,
and I think the
iterative process
of trying out some
visualizations,
seeing if it sticks, seeing if
it fits what Dom has in mind
for trying to report on this
stuff, was really valuable.
So I think, from a
high level perspective,
it's just the challenge of
trying to get this many data
sources visualized in exactly
the way he wanted it was really
the biggest challenge,
and I can't imagine.
There is no analog equivalent to
trying to do that without Cloud
architecture.
MARK MANDEL: Stewart, I got an
interesting question for you.
So, you mentioned
a little while ago
that you're using both App
Engine and Cloud Functions.
I know something we've
talked about in the past
is, where to apply, what
type of compute resource
to what sort of workload.
I'm curious to know how you made
the decision about what things
were going to end
up on App Engine
and what things would end up
on Cloud Functions and why.
STEWART BRYSON: So initially,
everything was in App Engine,
so that was just the
easiest way to do it.
We were pulling, and
in the App Engine code
we were pulling and
writing the BigQuery.
It was as we started ingesting
multiple data sources that we
realized we needed to respond to
this in more of an event driven
manner.
For instance, the Twitter
example, the streaming API
versus the batch API.
It would be difficult to
write that sort of two
headed process in App Engine,
so one of the easiest decisions
was to start ingesting
that stuff in the Pub/Sub
so that you could have
one Cloud Function that's
responding to the events as
they're going into Pub/Sub,
but then App Engine was able
to continue to do the streaming
side of it, so it
was the approach
to trying to both pull
from a streaming API,
and also periodically
process using the batch
API, some of those
same datasets.
We had to work through
what we thought
was the life of a tweet.
There's a lot of
thoughts on that,
but I think we decided
on seven days, right Dom?
So for seven days
we would continually
look at-- a tweet came
through the streaming API,
and it became very easy
with the Cloud Function
to respond to those
streaming tweets
and periodically go
query the batch API
to find out if there's been
any retweets, likes, et cetera.
MELANIE WARRICK: Do you have a
rough gauge for how much data
you were processing per
day, per minute, per hour?
STEWART BRYSON: It's really
not a lot when you look at it.
We've got some targeted
hashtags, targeted handles
for all these different
social media avenues,
and it's the other reason why
we shied away from Dataflow.
Dataflow can process huge
amounts of data at scale,
but it would have required us
to dip into Java or Python,
so the fact that App Engine
and Cloud Functions gave us
the ability to do a lot
of this in JavaScript,
and that's the best language
to be working with some
of the social media APIs.
MELANIE WARRICK: The
question I wanted to ask
is that since clearly you've
been using GCP products,
is this common that you see
these types of combinations?
What are some things
that you typically
see, or the type of products
that you need to put together
for your clients?
STEWART BRYSON: Yeah, really
when you start looking at,
is the data sitting
behind a REST API.
So in the past when
you-- especially
with on prem software,
it's everything's
so relational in nature, right?
Your source systems
are relational based.
Your target data warehouses
I think when you look
at where does GCP really
shine for analytics
workloads, and obviously it
can handle all of those
use cases as well,
but it's the API driven approach
that analytics is really
moving to today, and
that is that data
is coming from a lot of places.
It's not a single
source system that
has all of your information.
As more and more
companies our size,
and even companies the size
of Google, a lot of their data
is sitting in a lot of
disparate places, and the fact
that we can write these
event driven workflows that
can go grab this data
from behind a REST API,
process it in a
meaningful way, and also
the iterative approach for
which we were able to take
social media sources, architect
them from start to finish,
land them in BigQuery, and
start building reports in just
a few days.
So the value that
it really brings--
and I think Dom could speak
to this as well-- the value
that it really brings
is how quickly we were
able to hit the ground
running, how quickly we were
able to prototype a
particular digital channel,
develop a dashboard or in
a report in Data Studio,
get feedback, loop
back around and start
that iterative process again,
and we were constantly in flow
with building and delivering
additional data sets,
and just the interactive
and collaborative approach
that Data Studio takes is really
unlike any other visualization
tool that we've worked with.
The ability to be able to
just, everyone collaborate
on a Data Studio
report in the same way
you would with Google
Docs or Google Sheets,
it was really valuable
from that whole analytics
process of trying to get
exactly the right visualization
that Dom's team was
looking for, and that
took several iterations
to get it just right,
and we were able to do that
really easily in Data Studio.
MARK MANDEL: Dom, how is
the experience for you
of this being developed
as you being the end user?
DOM ELLIOTT: I agree with
most of what Stewart said.
It was great, actually.
I was constantly surprised
at what was possible, really.
It was really very helpful
doing everything iteratively
because I had rough ideas
at the very beginning,
but I didn't fully know what
was possible in these products,
and so I'd sit down
with Stewart and Phil
and we'd talk through
various ideas,
and they would let me
know what's possible,
and then they could go
away and just put something
together straightaway really
quickly, something scrappy,
and we'd have a look
at that, and then
we could keep iterating.
So it worked very well, and
then yeah, as you mentioned,
Data Studio has--
the front end UI is like using
Google Docs or something,
so I could jump in and toggle,
test out changing little things
myself without actually
going into the code.
MARK MANDEL: And Dom
I'm also wondering now
that you have this
tool, what's been
the most interesting
or surprising metric
that you've been able
to pull out of it
that you wouldn't
have necessarily would
have been able to do before?
DOM ELLIOTT: The data is
buried in different places.
Well, we didn't have the
sentiment data at all,
so that is really interesting.
Some of the things
I like the most
are diving into
different countries
and just seeing the
engagement that we
get in different countries.
Android is exploding
at the moment in--
we call them next for
the end user markets,
or growing markets like India,
and Vietnam, and Indonesia,
and I'm able to see
in this dashboard,
as well, going through
the various channels,
we have huge engagement
in those regions.
We can see specific
countries who are really,
really engaged on our
channel and consuming
all of this content, and that's
been really great, so we can
then see, OK, they're reading--
or this-- this
country, say Vietnam,
is really, really engaged
in reading all our content
in English, and so we can
do a better job there,
and we can go and localize the
content because the developer
audience is there, and produce
more content in Vietnamese
for them, so those kind of loops
have been really satisfying.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well, I know
we're getting close to time,
but I wanted to ask
you-- and both of you--
what are some key lessons
learned, takeaways,
that you haven't already talked
about that you'd recommend
to people who are considering
this type of project,
or something along these lines?
STEWART BRYSON: I
think, be iterative.
I've mentioned that
before, but jump in.
One of the best things about
the Google Cloud Platform
is that you can get
started on day one.
For instance, Data Studio
has direct connectors
to a lot of these
sources, and although we
knew that we wanted to
land the data in BigQuery
for posterity's sake, we were
able to prototype immediately
with the built in connectors to
things like YouTube and Google
Analytics, and start that whole
process of trying to figure out
exactly how Dom and his team
wanted to see that data.
So while we had one member of
the team with direct connectors
from Data Studio
working with Dom's team,
really on day one
prototyping some of the ways
that he was thinking about
visualizing this data.
We had other members
of the team working
on capturing that data using
things like App Engine,
writing that data to
BigQuery, figuring out
how we wanted to
store it in BigQuery,
and it was a complete iterative
process, so once the data--
it took us a little time
to get the data transfer
service running.
Once that data was
landing in BigQuery,
we slowly refactored Data
Studio reports and dashboards
to go after the BigQuery data.
In some instances we
continued to report
against the native connectors,
so we have dashboards
that blend content from the
native connectors with the data
from BigQuery, and that
flexibility was really
eye opening, I think.
In a lot of analytics projects
you spend so much time
trying to land and
ingest the data
and get the data
just right, and then
the analytics starts,
and quite often
that piece is kind of brushed
over because you're running out
of time, and maybe you
don't get exactly what
the end user was looking
for from a visualization
perspective.
We were able to start
the visualization
process immediately using
the native connectors,
and then just slowly
refactor over time,
so I think if I were to take
one major lesson from building
analytics, especially
a Greenfield
implementation in the
Google Cloud platform,
is just be iterative.
Roll up your sleeves, get
started, and also don't be
afraid to write a little code.
So with APIs, it's going to
be difficult to find just
the right tooling to go after
something that's API driven,
so you've got to not
be afraid to use tools
like Cloud Functions, use
a tool like App Engine
and Pub/Sub to build the right
event driven architecture.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
How about you, Dom?
DOM ELLIOTT: In general I
was just pleasantly surprised
at what's possible.
I think the kind of
small amount of work
up front is really worth it
to save time in the long run,
and you can--
then these reports
are very flexible
and can help you save time
and do your job better,
and on Data Studio
in particular,
I love a bunch of
their visualizations
we're using now, which we
just weren't using before.
Well, we weren't using
bubble charts at all before
and now they're one of my
favorite visualizations,
and we've got heat maps, and
geographic maps, and just
a bunch more
interesting, insightful
visualizations that
we can start to draw
interesting conclusions from.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
MELANIE WARRICK: It's expanding
your knowledge on the system.
DOM ELLIOTT: Yeah, exactly.
STEWART BRYSON: Let
me just jump in there
and say how easy it is
to change visualizations
and to test particular
visualizations.
Geography is particularly
easy in Data Flow.
It just knows when you're
dealing with geographic data.
The way it handles
time based prompts
for you to be able to
choose a particular time
frame for whether you want
quarterly, monthly, trending,
et cetera.
It just sort of gets
all that, so the built
in sort of functionality
for constants like geography
and time is really pleasing.
If you look at on prem versions
of this kind of software,
it's not near that easy,
so Data Studio really
shines in handling those
sorts of known data types.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
Well, we've definitely
run out of time,
but such a pleasure
talking to both of you.
Stewart, Dom, thank you for
spending the time with us today
to talk about what you've
been doing over at Google Play
with all your data
and Data Studio.
DOM ELLIOTT: Thanks
for having us.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes, thank you.
STEWART BRYSON: Yeah, thanks
very much for having me.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks so
much to Dom and Stewart
to have a chat with us
about Google Cloud Platform,
and how it was actually used
internally inside Google.
Not just external
customers use it.
We do have plenty of
internal customers as well,
so it was a really
interesting conversation.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah, I agree.
It's nice to hear about how the
Cloud Platform is being used
to solve problems that we know
others will be experiencing
whether they're
internal or external.
So, questions of the week.
If you want to be
able to unit test
your integrations with
Kubernetes with client go.
How can you mock what happens
inside the cluster in your unit
tests?
Mark?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
so this is something
I do a lot with because I muck
around with Kubernetes a lot.
Probably if you're familiar
at all with Kubernetes,
you may be familiar
with Cube CTL.
You're probably familiar
that from Cube CTL,
behind that is a Kubernetes API.
Client go is the go
client that you use for,
basically, talking
to Kubernetes.
So if you want to
programmatically create
pods or deployments,
or pretty much anything
inside Kubernetes, can do
that through client go.
What I don't know if is
as much known by people
is there's a whole
fake section to it that
enables you to basically mock
out how things work, so you
create a client
set with client go,
and then when you want to use
it in testing you can create
this fake client set,
and what you can do then
is add these things
called reactors to it,
and I'll put links
in the show notes.
Reactors are lovely in
that you can basically
control what happens when
things happen for the client's
[INAUDIBLE].
So you might be like, list
pods, and you'll add a list pods
reactor, and then
you'll be like,
these are the pods
that will be shown now,
and it'll work just like it
would do as if it was connected
to a real cluster, but you
just have full control over it,
and you can basically tell it
to do whatever it is you need
to do inside your unit tests.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's nice.
MARK MANDEL: It's
actually really nice.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Testing is hard enough,
so when you have something
that can help with that,
that's invaluable.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
so I'll put links
to the documentation
in the show notes.
I'll also link to
you some demo code
I have in one of my git
hub hub repositories so you
can see it in action as well.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
Mark, you going anywhere special
in the next couple weeks?
MARK MANDEL: Nope.
Same old answer as always,
game developer conference
here at Google.
The stuff I can
talk about is that.
We have a developer
day across Google
where we will have people from
Google Cloud Platform, people
from Daydream, people from
Play talking about that
on the first day of game
developers conference,
but we'll also have talks at
the booth on the show floor,
as well as meet the
expert sessions,
and all sorts of good stuff.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's great.
MARK MANDEL: And I think you're
away right now, I believe.
MELANIE WARRICK: I
will be away shortly,
and I will going to FAT* in
New York as I was talking about
earlier in the beginning
of this podcast,
and then I'll come back and
we'll get back in the studio
again and talk
about more things.
All the things.
MARK MANDEL: All
the things, awesome.
All right.
Well Melanie, thank you
so much for joining me yet
another week on the podcast.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Thank you, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: And thank
you all for listening,
and we'll see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]